EFFORTS.
CONGRESS RESPONDED BY NOT
RESPONDING MUCH AT ALL.
MIKE EMMANUEL TELLS US WHERE
THINGS STAND TONIGHT.
>> PROTESTERS BLOCKED TRAFFIC
TODAY A SHORT DISTANCE FROM THE
CAPITAL.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
DEADLINE FOR DACA.
>> WE'RE HERE TO SAY LOUD AND
CLEAR, NO WAY.
NO WAY.
>> NO WAY.
>> WE'RE GOING TO STAND WITH
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO CONGRESS
AND TO THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
TRUMP CREATED THIS CRISIS.
>> AT WHITE HOUSE SANDERS USED
CHOICE WORDS TO BLAME CONGRESS.
>> THE FACT THEY CAN'T GET
SOMETHING DONE AND NOW THEY USE
THE COURTS AS AN EXCUSE.
>> MINUTES LATER TRUMP BLASTED
AWAY ON TWITTER, IT IS MARCH 5th
AND DEMOCRATS NO WHERE TO BE
POUND ON DACA.
GAVE THEM SIX MONTHS AND THEY
DON'T CARE, WHERE ARE THEY.
WE'RE READY TO MAKE A DEAL.
AN ARIZONA CONSERVATIVE SAID THE
DREAMERS HAD NO ONE TO BLAME BUT
THEIR PARENTS.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT THE DREAMERS
SHOULD BE MAD AT ARE NOT THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS THEIR PARENTS THEY SHOULD
BE MAD AT.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT CAME
HERE I GO
HERE I G
HERE ILL
HERE ILLEG
HERE ILLEGAL
HERE ILLEGALLY
HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> THIS TOOK PRESSURE OFF
LAWMAKERS.
>> BECAUSE OF THE COURT'S
DECISION THAT THE DATE IS
MEANINGLESS, I THINKS IT IS
UNFORTUNATE, WE WORK BETTER WHEN
WE HAVE A DEADLINE.
>> PLEASE
>> PLEAS
>> PELAS
>> PELOS
>> PELOSI,
>> PELOSI, S
>> PELOSI, SAI
>> PELOSI, SAID
>> PELOSI, SAID T
>> PELOSI, SAID THE
>> PELOSI, SAID THEY
>> PELOSI, SAID THEY G
>> PELOSI, SAID THEY GOT
>> PELOSI, SAID THEY GOT T
>> PELOSI, SAID THEY GOT TO
STOP USING THESE PEOPLE AS
BARGAINS CHIPS.
HE SAID HIS SIDE DID A LOT.
>> WE PUT THE WALL ON THE
TABLE.
A FANTASTIC WASTE OF MONEY.
MAYBE GREAT ENGINEERING BUT
FANTASTIC WASTE OF MONEY.
>> BIGS IS DEMANDING SECURITY.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE WALL
FIRST.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE THAT IF YOU GIVE THE
AMNESTY.
>> OKLAHOMA STAR LANGFORD NOTES
IT WON'T BE EASY TO PROTECT THE
DREAMERS AND SECURE THE BORDERS.